sí
[Aplausos]
ella tenía 21 años en el 2013
tenía 21 años y vivía en la calle de
libertad
en la colonia tepito una de las colonias
más peligrosas de esta ciudad
ella tenía un amor y se llamaba gabriel
y gabriela tenía una chiquita de 8 años
y ese día le confesó que su tío paterno
había abusado sexualmente de ella le
había tocado con sus asquerosas manos
y gabriela le pidió que la acompañara a
denunciar
y ella se dirigió para acompañar a su
novia pero nunca llegó ellos la
levantaron los hermanos ramírez anaya la
levantaron la secuestraron a punta de
cuchillo la llevaron a un hotel de paso
y la golpearon
escupieron la violaron sexualmente y
tocaron su cuerpo de la manera más ruin
que se puede tocar el cuerpo de una
mujer
en legítima defensa le cortó el cuello a
uno de sus atacantes
uno había salido corriendo a lavar una
virgencita unos minutos antes
su agresor el otro salió corriendo
también y se murió frente a la
procuraduría capitalina eran vecinos
ella salió corriendo a pedir ayuda
esperando que aquellos que juraron velar
por nuestra seguridad iban a contener su
dolor ella sangraba y le dolía el cuerpo
le dolía el alma del le dolía su
dignidad y ellos la volvieron a engañar
y la llevaron a denunciar
y le dijeron que tenía oportunidad de
hacer lo que todos tenemos derecho
denunciar a nuestros agresores
y no fue así
ella fue detenida por homicidio
calificado ella fue llevada presa
al reclusorio de santa martha acatitla
por donde segunda ocasión intentó salvar
su vida porque por 30 pesos 30 pesos que
vale la vida de una mujer había sido
tratada de ser asesinada por segunda
ocasión por las internas del penal
y allí entré yo cuando vi el caso de
jackie y rubio en facebook cuando su
dolor me dolió a mí y decidí tomar esa
defensa cuando llegue a las rejillas de
práctica de santa martha acatitla y metí
mis manos en las rejillas ínfimas donde
se siente el frío y el abandono y el
olor a muerte y ella solo lloro
y yo juré por mi vida misma que no sabía
que tenía que hacer pero que iba a
regresar a la calle de libertad y ahí
empezó la confrontación con las
autoridades en donde sin miramientos y
con toda la indolencia del mundo
trataron de sostener una imagen de
instituciones que no se merecen ser
respetadas porque el respeto se gana con
el trabajo digno en busca de la justicia
y la verdad y este no fue el caso
recuerdo la primera ocasión que tuve
oportunidad de estar frente al juez de
la causa y me dijo no abogada como cree
usted viene a defender esta [ __ ] a esta
narco menudista porque eso somos todas
las mujeres que nos defendemos que somos
violentadas sexualmente unas [ __ ]
provocadoras parece mentira que resulta
igual de jodidos ser defensora de género
y derechos humanos en este país que ser
víctima de unos infra humanos
y ahí
solo a partir de contar la verdad solo a
partir de levantar la voz por una mujer
que su vida no valía menos que la mía
ni que el puesto de ningún procurador
ahí en ese ínfimo momento donde el dolor
de nuestra hermana de nuestros hermanos
se convierte en el nuestro
y decidí poner en riesgo la mía
porque a ellos no les gustó
a ellos no les gusta que hablemos con la
verdad pretenden sostener imágenes
porque no conozco una sola mujer en toda
mi vida que se atreva a levantar la mano
diciendo que no ha sido víctima de
violencia de género porque el feminismo
no es una corriente social
y una inclinación política y un discurso
de candidatos es una realidad social
recuerdo hace tiempo un gobernador decía
no muy inteligente de estos que en
méxico se caracteriza por tener pues es
que porque le hacen tanto al cuento si
aparecen hombres muertos todos los días
no señor
aparecen hombres muertos muertos a manos
de hombres hombres que matan hombres
hombres que matan mujeres porque nos
están matando porque la voz de las
víctimas se merma frente al lado de
nuestros atacantes porque sigue
existiendo la teoría de la víctima
provocadora que se generó por ahí de los
años 30
para que sales es ahora la calle
porque te vestiste así
porque no pediste ayuda
porque la reacción defensiva de las
mujeres en este país está condenada a
ser pasiva porque es claro que no
tenemos derecho a defendernos
y menos
después de ser violadas
recuerdo también una nota de periódico y
en las noticias hace un par de años que
hablaban de un señor un caballero que
andaba por las calles de polanco y en
las calles de polanco lo asaltaron
o pretendían asaltarlo pero el muy sagaz
mente sacó un arma de fuego y disparó
contra su asaltante y lo mató en
legítima defensa ese día ese día el
turbio calientito con su familia porque
en este país un reloj de balón de mano
vale mucho más que una vagina
porque no se nos concede el derecho a
defendernos porque al día de hoy no ha
habido una sola autoridad que se atreva
a hacer una resolución con perspectiva
de género
hoy aquí y está en la calle de libertad
hoy aquí y está libre
pero no creamos que este es un éxito es
una victoria pírrica timorata a medias
tintas' lechita tibia condescendiente
porque le otorgan el derecho a la
legítima defensa porque hay que
agradecerle al agresor que la apuñaló y
gracias a esa lesión que ella presentaba
en el cuerpo gracias a esas puñaladas
que presentaba en el cuerpo se acreditó
la legítima defensa y pasó lo mismo con
esta chiquita y giselle de 15 años hace
apenas ni un año que fue violada en las
calles de esta ciudad de mexico
y también mató a su agresor y también la
señalaron y la persiguieron por ser una
homicida
pero la sociedad conoce y la sociedad
aprende y le exigieron al procurador
capitalino que cesara su persecución que
se decretara la legítima defensa y
funcionó
pero nuevamente
porque la única razón por la que se la
otorgaron fue porque también había sido
apuñalada por su agresor y regresamos al
mismo cuestionamiento hasta cuándo vamos
a vivir con miedo cuántos de ustedes
tienen miedo de salir a la calle y ser
penetrado cuántos de ustedes son
señalados después de haber sido tocados
de una forma indigna por ser unos
provocadores
la violencia de género institucional se
vive todos los días después de esa gran
batalla después de esa lucha contra el
sistema tuve la oportunidad de escribir
un libro un libro que titulé en legítima
defensa
un libro que me ha costado años de ser
perseguida por las instituciones
mexicanas
un libro que ha tenido repercusiones y
ha hecho que hoy pertenezca a un sistema
de protección nacional porque llevó dos
atentados de muerte porque no me quiero
callar y no me voy a callar ya no más
yo ya estoy hasta la madre de sentir
miedo y aquí en estas aulas en esta
universidad gran semillero de
profesionistas les pido que hagamos
humanas nuestras profesiones que nos
desvinculemos al ser humano que no
sigamos cayendo en la indolencia porque
eso genera impunidad porque ellos se
regocijan de nuestro miedo porque se
regocijan de evitar y comunicar cuáles
son nuestros derechos
como abogada como mujer como defensora
de derechos humanos y defensora de
género
hoy les suplico entereza constancia
ni una más ni una mujer asesinada más
pueden ser sus madres o sus hermanas o
pueden ser las mismas madres que han
visto llorar siendo violentadas por sus
padres
dejemos de normalizar la violencia
dejemos de normalizar el dolor no
tenemos que vivir así ellos se han
encargado de tapear todos sus errores y
sostener imágenes insostenibles que no
se merecen ellos prometieron cumplir con
su deber
y qué hacemos hoy los que estamos
comprometidos y que hacemos hoy los que
sentimos el dolor de nuestro vecino
resistir
pero nunca callar
nunca más volver a bajar la cabeza la
violencia de género se está en todos los
rubros de la vida
cuando alguien refiere es que tu novio
es muy celoso lo que pasa es que es un
poquito controlador no señora su pareja
es un delincuente los legisladores han
estudiado perfectamente el tipo de
afectación psicoemocional que se vive
después de ser violentada para
establecer esas conductas como un delito
es un delito y merece ser señalado
y señalará al agresor
porque tenemos derecho a vivir una vida
libre de violencia
hoy
con toda la rabia que me sumerge al
sentirme perseguida
que yo no voy a parar no solo lastiman a
quien levanta la voz lastiman a aquellas
víctimas que se sienten cobijadas por
una representación de alguien que está
dispuesta a poner su vida de por medio
por obtener su libertad por restablecer
el estado de derecho que las propias
autoridades han violentado
y me me me duele en el alma
me duele la indolencia me duele la
indiferencia
me duele tu dolor
y me duele el tuyo
este libro es una bitácora con nombres y
apellidos de todos aquellos que pensaron
que el miedo que creían o pretendían
generar en mí iba a callar mi voz y no
porque lo haya escrito yo es importante
sino porque todos merecemos saber qué
tipo de autoridades nos representan
cuánta violencia tenemos que seguir
sosteniendo y soportando en este
transitar qué importa quién sea el
presidente que importa quién sean los
diputados que quedan pero si hay que
estudiarlos porque los derechos se
exigen no se mendigan
y para poder exigir los hay que
conocerlos hay que comprometernos con
nosotros mismos con nuestra sociedad
sólo así podemos transitar en un mundo
en un mundo misógino y patriarcal
y preguntan y las servidoras públicas
que violentan a otras mujeres no las
justifico pero si las entiendo saben
cuánto cuesta entrar a un sistema
machista y ser exitosa saben cuántas
veces tenemos que bajar la cabeza cuando
nos toman por la entrepierna un
presidente del tribunal
saben cuántas veces sentimos asco
por como nos tocan
la violencia de género es una constante
yo los invito a que se comprometan con
sus compañeras con sus hermanas con sus
madres
por ellas por tus vecinas por tus hijas
porque esto no es una cuestión de viejas
ximo leras como nos llaman cuando
levantamos la voz
porque como se les aplaude a los
abogados que defienden a los políticos
que han asesinado el país entero
esto se trata del alma
y a nosotras nos llaman argüenderos y a
ellos grandes juristas a ellos los que
ni siquiera conocen su ley los que
litigan a billetazos
a ellos también hay que suplicarle que
no desvinculen la exigencia de verdad y
justicia con el dolor de la gente
denunciando y nunca callando
denunciando y nunca callando por nada ni
nadie quien sea los abusadores son solo
eso unos abusadores sedientos de poder
me preguntaban si tenía miedo miedo de
que me lastimen físicamente claro que lo
tengo
pero no más miedo hacia ellos no más
miedo a sus represalias
el miedo nunca me ha detenido y esta no
va a ser ni la primera ni la última vez
que yo esté parada aquí o en cualquier
lugar pidiendo acción
unámonos
ustedes están empezando una carrera sea
cual la que sea no importa
las profesiones se dan entre humanos
entre pieles entre emociones
que nos duela el dolor ajeno
que nos duela
la violencia que nos duela la vida a mí
me duele
y aquí estoy para ustedes
[Música]
yo